สวัสดีค่ะครูป๊าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนวันนี้เรามา
เจอกันวันอะไรคะครูฟ้าวันนี้เรามาเจอกัน
วันพุธค่ะวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
25 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มกราคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 แล้วปีค.ศล่ะคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
โอเคกี่โมงแล้วคะครู
ฟ๊า
14  27 นค่ะ
นอืครูฟ้าสบายดีมยครูฟ้าสบายดีค่ะครูเด
แข็งแรงดีหรอรีมเห็นครูฟ้า
แบบเออนั่นสิูฟ้าจะบอกสบายดีดีมั้ยคะเออ
ิมก็เลยถามจริงๆก็ไม่สบายไม่สบายนิดหน่อย
นะ 50% แล้วกันค่ะ 50% นี่ไม่นิดหน่อยนะ
ไม่นิดหน่อยครูพระยังไม่ค่อยสบายเท่าไหร่
นะคะต้องไปโรงพยาบาลอ๋อแต่ไม่รู้วันไหน
เดี๋ยวเช็คดูอีกทีนึงนะคะเพราะว่านี่ไง
ยังมีที่คออยู่นะคะ
อืนเห็นมั้ยมันใหญ่ขึ้นมาต้องไปโรงพยาบาล
ก่อนนะคะอือ๋อโอเคแต่ว่าครูฟ้าโอเคใช่
มั้ยคะวันนี้วันนี้โอเคค่ะครูเรียมครูฟ้า
เนี่ยสบายดีครูเรียมสบายดีมยสบายดีค่ะครู
ฟ้าขอบคุณค่ะกินข้าวหรือยังคะกินข้าว
เรียบร้อยแล้วค่ะโอเคค่ะถ้าอย่างงั้นครู
เรียมก็พร้อมฟังครูฟ้าเล่านิทานแล้วใช่มย
พร้อมค่ะพร้อมมากๆค่ะ
95%  95% อีก 5% ไปไหนคะอีก 5% ก็แบบกิน
ข้าวเสร็จแล้วก็ง่วงง่วงง่วงนิดหน่อยง่วง
5%  5% ใช่่มั้ยก็เลยพร้อม
95 เยอะแล้วค่ะ 95% นี่เยอะมากเลยค่ะนัก
เรียนก็พร้อมใช่มั้ยคะฟังครูฟ้านะคะใช่
ค่ะครูฟ้ามีาเยอะนะไม่ต้องหครูฟ้าเรียม
รู้สึกกลัวหนังสือนิทานเล่มนี้มากทำไมค่ะ
ครูเร็วเรมรู้เรมคิดว่าหนังถือหนังสือ
นิทานของครููฟ้าครูฟ้าเอามาเล่าแล้วมัน
ไม่เหมือนกับนิทานของคนอื่น
ๆ
ใช่มันคนละเวอร์ชั่นกันเลยค่ะใช่ใช่มเรา
ก็เลยต้องมาฟังให้ครูฟ้าเล่าให้ฟัง
อืได้เลยค่ะครูเรียมแล้วนิทานที่ครูฟ้าจะ
เล่าวันนี้ชื่อเรื่องอะไรนะคะชื่อเรื่อง
กระเป๋านะคะ
เอิ่มหมวกนะคะหมวกหมวกใช่มั้ยแล้วก็เขา
ควายว่ามีรูปนะ
ออเรียมกำลังจะหา
หมวกแต่มันอยู่ไกลมากอยู่ไกลมากอ่านะคะ
เดี๋ยวครูปัเปิดรูปให้ดูได้ค่ะนี่โอเคเ
เห็น
มอันนี้คือกระเป๋ากระเป๋าหรือว่าจริงๆมัน
คือย่ามนะคะนักเรียนถ้าเป็นชื่อนิทาน
เวอร์ชั่นภาษาอังกฤษจะเรียกว่า
ย่ามย่ามก็คือกระเป๋ามภาษาไทยนะคะนัก
เรียนยกระเป๋านะแต่แบบจะเป็นอีกแบบนึงนะ
ครูฟ้ากระอืย่ามมันจะอีกอย่างนึงนะคะแต่
ครูฟ้าลองเอาภาษาอังกฤษไปเสิร์ชใน Google
มันออกมาเป็นแบบนี้อก็เลยไม่รู้ว่า
ฝรั่งใช้อะไรนะคะเรียกกระเป๋าก็ได้นะคะ
นักเรียนกระเป๋าแล้วก็
เอ่อหมวกใช่
มยหมวกแี่พตนะคะอจริงเหมือนหมวกแี่พตใช่
แล้วก็เขาควาย
อ้าเขาอย่างงี้
อืมอันนี้คือชื่อเรื่องค่ะ
โอเคมันจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นเกิดอะไรขึ้นใช่ค่ะ
คุกาละครั้งหนึ่งนานมาแล้วนะคะมีผู้ชาย 3
คนเป็นพี่น้องกัน
อืม 3 คนเ
จนไม่มีเงินไม่มีอาหารนะคะ
ออจนมากๆ
อืหิวบ้านก็เล็กๆนะคะแล้วก็อาหารก็ไม่มี 3
คนก็เลยคุยกันว่า
อืมเราจะต้องเดินออกไปข้างนอกไปหาอาหารไป
หาเงินแล้วล่ะอืมอ๋อถ้าโชคดีใช่มยโชคดีก็
อาจจะได้เงินก็ได้อือ๋อ 3 คนนี้เคอยู่ใน
บ้านด้วยกัน 3 คนไม่มีพ่อกับแม่เหรอคะครู
ฟ้าไม่มีพ่อแม่ค่ะครูเรียมครูคิดว่าเโต
แล้วอายุ 20  21  25 อะไรอย่างเงี้ยโต
แล้วไม่มีพ่อแม่นะคะอือืซึ่ง 3 คนเนี่ยก็
เลยคุยยกันแล้วก็บอกว่าโอเคเราจะเดินออก
ไปข้าง
นอกคิดว่าน่าจะมีโชคดีค่ะอือืก็เลยออกจาก
บ้านไปนะคะ 3 คนแล้วก็ไปไกลเลยเดินไปใน
ป่า
อืวันนึงเนี่ย 3 คนนี้เนี่ยก็มีเห็นป่านะ
คะแล้วก็เลยเดินเข้าไปในป่าใช่มั้ยนัก
เรียนต้นไม้ต้นไม้ต้นไม้เยอะๆแล้วเรียก
ว่าป่านะคะป่าอเมซอนหรือเปล่าไม่รู้นะคะ
ไม่รู้ใช่ค่ะพอเดินเข้ามาถึงเข้าไปในป่า
เนี่ยก็เห็นภู
เขา
อืเห็นภูเขาเล็กๆนะคะอต้องภูเขาเล็กๆใช่
มั้ยภูเขาเล็ก
ๆกอภูขาเล็กๆใช่ค่ะซึ่งพอ 3 คนเดินเข้าไป
ใกล้ๆภูเขาก็เห็นว่าที่ภูเขาเนี่ยมีเงิน
เป็นภูเขาของเงินค่ะครู
เรียมภูเขาอันนี้ก็คือเงินหรอคะครูฟ้าใช่
ค่ะเงินสุดยอดเรียมกำลังคิดอยู่เลยว่า 3
คนนี้เดินเข้าไปหาหาอะไรในป่าหาอะไรใช่ไม
เนี่ยเข้าในป่าน่าจะมีของกินเออมี
แอปเปิ้ลมีกล้วย
อืแต่เจอเงินเออไม่ไม่คิดว่าจะมีเงินใน
ป่าเพราะว่า 3 คนโชคดีนะคะอ้าโชคดีก็เลย
เจอเงินใช่ไหมอพี่ชายคนโตอายุมากที่สุด
เนี่ยบอกว่าฉันโชคดีแล้วฉันไม่อยากได้
อะไร
แล้วแล้วพี่ชายเนี่ยก็เลยหยิบเงินใส่
กระเป๋ามมีกระเป๋านะคะหยิบเงินเงินเอา
เงินใส่กระเป๋าใส่กระเป๋านะคะแล้วก็เดิน
กลับ
บ้านก็เหลือ 2 คนใช่มยพี่ชายกับน้องชายนะ
คะ 2 คนเนี่ยก็เลยบอกว่าเราไม่เอาเงิน
หรอกอืเงินเนี่ยก็ดีแต่ไม่เอาหรอกเราต้อง
เดินไปอีกอาจจะมีอะไรที่ดีกว่าเงิน
ออ 2 คนนี้ก็ไม่เอาเงินใส่กระเป๋าหรอไม่
ค่ะยังไม่กลับบ้านเดินเข้าไปในป่าอีก 2
คนก็เดินเข้าไปอีก 2 วันนะคะใช้เวลา 2
วันก็เจอภูเขาอีกค่ะครูเรียม
ออเจอภูเขาเล็กมั้ยหรือว่าภูเขาใหญ่ๆ
เอิ่มเป็นภู
เขาน่าจะปานกลางมั้งน่าจะปานกลางเค้าไม่
ได้บอกใช่มั้ยูปาากลางเคไม่ได้บอกเ้าไม่
ได้บอกเดาอ้าแล้วภูเขามีอะไรหรือเปล่าคะ
มีเงินอีกมั้ยโไม่มีเงินค่ะครูเรียมแต่
ว่าภูเขานี้นะคะมีทองภูเขาทองทองๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆ
ๆทองเป็นมเยอะมากเลยนะคะนัก
เรียนรวยกว่าเงินอีกอ่ะใช่อืแล้วเค้าเอา
ทองใส่กระเป๋ามั้ย
ซึพี่ชายคนที่ 2 เนี่ยก็พูดว่าทำยังไงดี
ล่ะฉันควรจะเอาทองใส่กระเป๋าแล้วก็กลับ
บ้านดีมั้ยหรือจะไปกับน้องชายต่อ
อีกพี่ชายบอกว่างคแต่ก็พี่ชายคนที่ 2 ก็
คิดว่าโอเคงั้นไม่เอาอะไรและมีทองเดีกว่า
มีเงินนะคะเอาทองะกันก็เลยเอาทองใส่
กระเป๋าค่ะใส่กระเป๋าใส่กระเป๋าแล้วก็
เดินกลับบ้านออ้ากลับบ้านคนเดียวเหรอคะ
ครููฟ้าใช่ค่ะครูเรียมกลับบ้านคนเดียวค่ะ
น้องชายเนี่ยนะคะคนที่ 3 เนี่ยน้องชาย
เนี่ยก็พูดว่าฉันจะไม่เอาเงินฉันจะไม่เอา
ทองทองคำเนี่ยไม่เอาแต่ฉันจะเดินต่อไปอาจ
จะมีอะไรที่ดีกว่าเงินและก็ทองคำอ๋อแต่
ว่าน้องชายคนที่ 3 ก็ไม่รู้ใช่มั้ยว่าจะ
ไปเจอไปเจออะไรไม่รู้ค่ะครูเรียมคิดว่า
เดินต่อไปดีกว่าแล้วก็เดินๆเดินต่อไปนะ
คะนน้องชายคนที่ 3 เนี่ยเดินไปอีก 3 วัน
ว้าวเดินไปคนเดียวอีก 3 วันใช่ใช่ค่ะก็
เดินเข้าไปในป่าอีกนะคะนี้ก็เป็นป่าๆๆๆ
ทั้งนั้นเลยน้องชายคนที่ 3 เเดินเข้ามา
แล้วก็ปีนขึ้นไปบนต้นไม้อืเพราะว่าอยากจะ
รู้ว่า
เอ๊ตอนเอยู่ในป่าถ้าจะออกจากป่าเนี่ยต้อง
ไปทางไหนใช่มยปีนต้นไม้เค้าก็เลยอปีนขึ้น
ไปปีนขึ้นไปเป็นโคร่าเลยนะคะปีนต้นไม้
ขึ้นไปปีนปีนแล้วก็มาอยู่บนต้นไม้แล้วทำ
อะไรคะก็กำลังมองวิวนะคะว่า
เอ๊ที่ไหนอยากออกไปข้างนอกแล้วเพราะว่า
ตอนนี้เนี่ยเดินมาตั้งนานหิวออไม่มีอาหาร
กินเลยเลยนะคะต้องหาอาหารกินก่อนเค้าเนี่
ก็คิดทำยังไงดีน้ามันหิวจังแล้วก็พูดนะคะ
น้องชายคนที่ 3 เนี่ยพูดว่าถ้าฉันได้กิน
อาหารดีๆฉันก็คงจะเดินต่อไปได้
อืมพอพูดจบนะคะ
คูเรียมอยู่ๆเนี่ยก็มีอันนี้ค่ะอ่ะอะไรคะ
ครู
ฟ้าึเป็น
ผ้าเค้าเรียกอะไรเสื่อหรือเปล่าผ้า
อิมมันก็ไม่ออกแนวเสื่อเป็นผ้าอย่างเดียว
ค่ะครูเหลี่ยมอันนี้อาจจะใหญ่นะคะนัก
เรียนแต่ครูฟ้าคิดว่าน่า
จะน่าจะเล็กๆประมาณนี้มั้ง
อืผ้าปูโต๊ะหรอผ้าปิกนิกมยใช่เค้าเรียก
ผ้าผ้าเอาไว้ปูปูแล้วก็นั่งใช่มเอาไว้
นั่งนะคะเอ่อเราจะเรียกว่า
ผ้าปิกนิกละกันผ้า
ปูโตะเพราะว่าเอาไว้ปิกนิกละกันเป็นผ้า
แบบนี้นะคะอยู่ๆก็มีผ้าปิกนิกเนี่ยอยู่
ใต้ต้นไม้ค่ะโคแรมอ
อ้อแล้วบนผ้านั้นน่ะก็มีอาหารอาหารอาหาร
อาหารเยอะมากมีสเตกสปาเกตตี้พิซซ่า
โอสูยอาหารดีๆส้มิด้วแซลมอนต้มยำกุ้งโอ้
ต้มยำกุ้งด้วยนะคะมีอาหารดีๆเต็มเลยอื
เค้าก็คิดว่า
เอ๊ะทำไมพอพูดปุ๊บก็มีอาหาร
มาเกิดอะไรขึ้นใช่เกิดอะไรขึ้นแต่พราะ
ความหิวนะคะก็เลยรีบปีนลงมาแล้วก็กินๆๆๆๆ
พอกินเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยเค้าก็พับนะคะผ้า
ปิกนิกเนี่ยคะให้เล็กพับๆๆๆแล้วก็ใส่ไว้
ในกระเป๋าอืมเอาไปด้วยอืมเอาผ้าปิกนิกไป
ด้วยเ้าไม่ไม่คิดหรอว่าผ้าปิกนิกกับอาหาร
เป็นของใครไม่คิดค่ะหิวก็เลยกินๆๆอืนั่น
แหละซึ่งเค้าก็คิดว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยชันเนี่ย
มีโชคดีมากๆเพราะว่าภาพบิ๊กดิ๊กอันเนี้ย
ดีกว่าเงินดีกว่าทองใช่มยเพราะว่ามันมี
อาหารขึ้นมาจากผ้าไงนักเรียนอืโอสุดยอด
แล้วเ้าจะกลับบ้านกลับบ้านมั้ยคะครูฟ้า
ไม่ค่ะเค้าเนี่ยบอกว่าอืมก็โชคดีนะแต่
อยากโชคดีมากกว่านี้นะคะเค้าก็เลยเดิน
เดินๆๆเดินต่อ
ไปจนกระทั่งเข้าไปเจอบ้านหลังนึงค่ะครู
เรียมบ้านหลังใหญ่มั้ยคะเป็นบ้านเอ่อไม่
ใหญ่ค่ะบ้านหลังเล็กๆนะคะเป็นบ้านของคน
เผาถ่านอันนี้คือถ่านใช่มยค่ะ
รูเซฟมาแค่นี้เหรอคะทำไมน้อยจังเป็นบ้าน
ของคนเผาถานค่ะนะคะ
อันเนี้ย
คนเผาถ่านเนี่ยก็ไม่ใช่คนรวยหรอกอืก็มี
บ้านเล็กๆนะคะบ้านเล็กๆแล้วก็คนเผาถ่าน
เนี่ยกำลังทำมันฝรั่งฟ้าก็ลืมแชร์แล้ว
เปิดรูปมันฝรั่งให้ดูเลยแป๊บนึงนะแชร์
เมื่อกหมายถึงแบบคนเผาถ่านกำลังทำ
อาหารใช่ทำอาหารทำมาฝรั่งกินใช่มยใช่ค่ะ
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าคนเผาถ่านเนี่ยก็ไม่ได้รวย
มากอืก็เผาถ่านแล้วก็ได้เงินนิดหน่อยนะคะ
นี่อันนี้คือมันฝรั่งใช่มั้ยคะที่นัก
เรียนเอาไปทำเฟรนช์ไายนะ
คะคนเผาถ่านเนี่ยก็กำลังทำมันฝรั่ง
บาร์บีคิวอเราบอกว่าปิ้งอืปิ้งมันฝรั่ง
ปิ้งมันฝรั่งใช่
และน้องชายเนี่ยนะคะเค้าก็เลยเดินเข้าไป
หาคนเผาถานแล้วก็บอกว่า
สวัสดีฉันเนี่ยเดินผ่าน
มาคุณกำลังทำอะไรอืมอืคนเผาทหารก็เลยบอก
ว่าฉันเนี่ยเกำลังจะกินอาหารเย็น
อืฉันมีแต่มันฝรั่งอย่างเดียวกินมันฝรั่ง
ทุก
วันตอนเช้าก็มันฝรั่งตอนกลางวันก็กินมัน
ฝรั่ง
ตอนเย็นก็กินมันฝรั่งกินมันฝรั่งทุกๆวัน
เลยนะคะเชอบหรือเปล่าครูฟ้าเขาชอบกินมัน
ฝรั่งมาก
ๆชอบไหมนะ
คะไม่รู้นะคะหรือว่าแบบไม่มีอะไรให้กิน
แล้วมีมันฝรั่งอย่างเดียวจนค่ะใช่เขาไม่
มีเงินมีแค่มันฝรั่งเขาก็เลยชวนนะคะน้อง
ชายคนที่ 3 เนี่ยบอกว่าว่าชวนคนเผาถาด
เนี่ยบอกว่ากินด้วยกันมยฉันมีแค่มันฝรั่ง
อย่างเดียวเออถ้าเธอโอเคก็มากินด้วยกันอื
มาๆมากินด้วยกันมากินด้วยกัน
ซึ่งชายคนนี้นะคะน้องชายเนี่ยนะคะก็บอก
ว่าขอบคุณมากเลยแต่ฉันไม่กินของท่านหรอก
อืไม่กินของคุณ
หรอกมันฝรั่งเนี่ยมีนิดหน่อยมันน้อยมาก
เอาอย่างงี้ดีกว่าฉันอยากให้คุณมากิน
อาหารกับฉันโอเค
ยคนเผาถานก็งงไหนล่ะอาหารไม่เห็นถืออะไร
มาเลยอไม่มีปลาไม่มีไก่ไม่มีหมูอาหารอยู่
ที่ไหนอเค้าแบบจะมีโทรศัพท์หรือเปล่าแล้ว
ก็ฟู้แบฟู้ดแพนด้าหรือเปล่าแบฟู้ดหรือ
เปล่าค่ะมีมนะคะซึ่งอยู่ในป่านะอยู่ในป่า
อยู่นะน้องชายเนี่ยนะคะก็หยิบผ้าขึ้นมา
ใช่มยแล้วก็วางผ้าเสร็จแล้วก็บอกว่าอื้า
จ๋าขออาหารเยอะๆ
เลยขออาหารพอพูดจบนะคะก็มีเนื้อมีสเต็กมี
อาหารเต็มไปหมดอืกำลังร้อนเลยนะคะหอม
มากหอมมยหอมมากๆ
เออ 2 คนเนี่ยคนเผาถ่านก็ตกใจนะคะแล้วก็
นั่งลงแล้วก็กินอาหารจนอิ่มเลยอื
ออ
ซึ่งคนเผาถ่านก็เลยบอกว่าฉันเนี่ยชอบผ้า
ของคุณมากเลยเออถ้าฉันมีผ้าอันนี้นะนะ
ชีวิตก็คงจะดีเพราะว่าฉันอยู่ใน
ป่าหาอาหารเนี่ยไม่ค่อยได้
อืมเรามาคุยกันนิดนึงได้
มยคุยอะไร
หรอฉันขอแลกผ้าคือฉันเนี่ยก็มีของดีๆอยู่
นะมีกระเป๋า 1 ใบอือฮึกระเป๋าเนี่ยมัน
เก่าแล้วแหละอ้าแต่มันเป็นของที่ดีมากๆ
เลยถ้าท่านให้ผ้ากับฉันฉันจะให้กระเป๋าไป
อืมอ้าคุณเผากระเป๋าเก่า 10 ปี 20 ปีที่
แล้วมันจะดีได้ยังไงใช่มั้ยน้องชายก็เลย
บอกว่าเอ้าแล้วมันดียังไงล่ะกระเป๋าวัน
นั้นน่ะคนเผาารนก็เลยบอกว่าถ้าใช้มือนะคะ
ตบกระเป๋า 3 ที
1  2  3 อืตบกระเป๋าเนี่ยก็จะมีทหารออก
มาจากกระเป๋าหรอทหารนะคะนักเรียนมี
ทหารออกมาจากกระเป๋านี่เลยมีทหารเนี่ย 6
7 คน 7 คนนะคะตบกระเป๋า 3 ทีปึ๊บๆๆแล้ว
ก็มีทหารออกมา 7 คนมันดียังไงคะนั่นน่ะสิ
มันดียังไงแต่น้องชายคนที่ 3 เนี่ยนะคะก็
บอกว่า
อืมก็คงก็ได้ฉันให้ผ้าไปก็ได้ถึงฉันจะไม่
รู้ว่าเอาทหารไปทำ
อะไรใช่แต่ก็โอเคคุณเอาผ้าไปแล้วฉันก็เอา
กระเป๋ามา
โอเคเสร็จแล้วนะคะก็
บ๊ายบายน้องชายคนที่ 3 เก็บ๊ายบายคนเผา
ถ่านแล้วก็เดินๆๆๆต่อไปก็คิดเทสหน่อยดี
กว่าก็เลยตบกระเป๋า 3 ที 1  2  3 นะคะ
แล้วอยู่ๆเนี่ยก็มีทหารเดินเข้ามา 7 คน
ทหารก็ถามว่าอยากให้พวกเราทำ
อะไร
อ๋อน้องชายคนที่ 3 เก็บอกว่าทหารชันอยาก
ให้เธอไปบ้านของคนเผาถ่านแล้วไปเอาผ้า
ปิกนิกมาให้ฉัน
อ้าวจีเนียสมั้ยคะนักเรียนเออก็ไม่ค่อย
โอเคเท่าไหร่อือเป็นคนที่แบบซึ่งฉลาดนะ
แต่แบบ
เอ๊ะให้ผ้าคนเผาถ่านไปแล้ว
เอ้อทหารเนี่ยนะคะก็โอเคแล้วก็เดินๆๆๆ
เดินไปหาคนเผาถานแล้วก็ไปเอาผ้ามาแล้วก็
เดินเอาผ้ากลับมาให้น้องชายคนที่ 3 นะคะ
อืซึ่งน้องชายเรู้สึกแบบว่า
เออก็เป็นของที่ดีเหมือนกันตอนนี้เนี่ยมี
ของอยู่ครบเลยนะคะผ้าปิกนิกก็ยังอยู่ได้
กระเป๋ามาด้วยก็คิดเดินต่ออีกนิดหน่อยดี
กว่าเผื่อจะมีอะไรดี
ๆครูฟ้าจะย่อนะคะเพราะว่าเดี๋ยวมันหมด
เวลาน้องชายคนที่ 3 เนี่ยก็เดินไปบ้านของ
คนเผาถ่านอีก 2 คนแล้วก็ได้ของกลับมาอีก 2
อย่างค่ะครูเรียมก็คือหมวกอะไ
ออหมวกอันนี้เนี่ยถ้าตบไปบนหมวกแล้วเนี่ย
จะมีปืนปั้งๆๆๆๆมีปืนๆๆออกมาจากหมวกนะคะ
แล้วก็เขาควายใช่มยค่ะเขาควายเนี่ยถ้า
เกิดเป่า
เป่าอืบ้านนะคะเป่าเขาควายนะคะทำให้บ้าน
ที่อยู่ใกล้ๆอ่ะพังๆๆลงมาอืถ้ามีบ้านบ้าน
ก็จะพังนะคะเวลาเป่าเขาควายแล้วเนี่ย
เมืองพังบ้านพังทุกอย่างพังอ้าแล้วมันดี
ยังไงคะนั่นสิมันดียังไงนะคะและ
น้องชายเนี่ยก็เลยรู้สึกว่าโอเคและอืสบาย
ใจกลับบ้านดีกว่าพอกลับมาถึงที่บ้านเนี่ย
ก็เห็นว่าพี่ชาย 2 คนเนี่ยเอาเงินเอาทอง
มาสร้างบ้านใหญ่มากใช้ชีวิตดีกินอาหารดีๆ
มีความสุขนะฮะน้องชายเนี่ยก็เลยเดินเข้า
มาในบ้านแต่ด้วยความที่น้องชายเนี่ยเสื้อ
ผ้าก็เก่าๆหมวกก็เก่ากระเป๋าก็เก่าดูแล้ว
แบ
พี่ชายก็เลยไม่ให้น้องชายอยู่ในบ้านค่ะ
ไล่ออกไปออกไปออกไปออกไปโหพี่ชายแกไม่ใช่
น้องชายของฉันใช่นี่คือพี่ชายนะคะและออก
ไปเดี๋ยวนี้คนจนไม่มีเงิน
อ๋อน้องชายเนะคะโดนไล่ออกไปก็เลยโกรธมาก
น้องชายเนี่ยก็เลยตบกระเป๋าหลายๆครั้งเลย
นะคะตบๆๆๆๆทำให้มีทหาร 150 คนเดินเข้ามา
ว้าวเข้ามาที่บ้านของพี่ชายเหรอค่ะใช่ค่ะ
แล้วก็น้องชายเนี่ยก็สั่งให้ทหารเนี่ยนะ
คะเอาไม้ยาวๆไปตีพี่
ชายตีจนกว่าพี่ชายจะขอโทษ
ขอโทษขอโทษขอโทษตีนะคะอพี่ชายเนี่ยก็ร้อง
เสียงดังเพราะว่าโดนตีๆจนเจ็บเลยนะคะ
เกือบตายแล้วทีนี้เนี่ยเรื่องเนี่ยว่ามี
เค้าเรียกว่าอะไรก็มีพระราชาใช่มยพระราชา
ได้ยินว่ามีคนไม่กลัวเลยใช้ทหารไปทำร้าย
คนอื่นๆอืพระราชาก็เลยบอกทหารของพระราชา
ให้มาจับผู้ชายคน
นี้แต่ด้วยความที่ว่าน้องชายคนที่ 3
เนี่ยเค้ามีกระเป๋าใช่มยเค้าเนี่ยเรียก
ทหารได้เยอะมากๆนะคะทำให้เค้าเนี่ยชนะ
ทหาร
อืของพระราชาพระราชาเนี่ยสู้ไม่ได้
อ่าพระราชาก็เลยบอกว่าโอเคถ้างั้นมาคุย
กันเธอจะเอาอะไรน้องชายคนที่ 3 ก็บอกว่า
ขอแต่งงานกับเจ้าหญิงได้มย
ออ
อืแล้วพระราชาพระราชาให้เจ้าหญิงแต่งงาน
กับคนนี้มยพระราชาก็ต้องให้ค่ะเพราะว่า
สู้ไม่ได้นะคะก็ไปบอกเจ้าหญิงว่าต้องแต่ง
งานกับผู้ชายคนนี้นะเจ้าหญิงเนี่ยก็ไม่
ชอบใช่มยเพราะว่าผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยน้องชาย
คนที่ 3 เนี่ยใส่หมวกเก่าๆมีเสื้อเก่าๆดู
เหมือนคนจนนะคะแต่เจ้าหญิงเนี่ยก็รู้สึก
ว่าเอ๊ผู้ชายคนนี้ต้องมีอะไรแน่เลยก็เลย
แอบดูนะคะก็เห็นว่าผู้ชายเนี่ยมีกระเป๋า
อ่าเจ้าหญิงเนี่ยก็เลยไปขโมยกระเป๋ามา
แล้วก็รีบวิ่งหนี
อืแต่น้องน้องชายคนที่ 3 เนี่ยพอเห็นเจ้า
หญิงหยิบกระเป๋าไปนะคะแล้วเจ้าหญิงเนี่ย
ก็ตบกระเป๋าให้ทหารวิ่งออกมาอ๋อทหารเนี่ย
ก็วิ่งออกมาเพื่อที่จะสู้กับน้องชายคนที่
3 ใช่มยน้องชายคนที่ 3 เนี่ยก็เลยตบไป
ที่หมวกนะคะทำให้หมวกเนี่ยมีปืนแล้วก็ยิง
ๆๆๆตายทั้ง
หมดออเจ้าหญิงพอสู้ไม่ได้เนี่ยก็เลยเดิน
กลับมาแล้วก็บอกว่าขอโทษฉันจะไม่ทำอีก
แล้ว
อืแต่เจ้าหญิงก็พยายามหาวิธีฉันต้องเอา
หมวกมาให้ได้
อืซึ่งเจ้าหญิงก็ขโมยหมวกมาได้ค่ะแล้วก็
ใช้หมวกเนี่ยยิงไปที่น้องชายคนที่ 3 นะฮะ
อ้าน้องชายคนที่ 3 ก็รีบวิ่งหนีใช่มั้
เพราะว่าโดนยิงสุดท้ายแล้วเนี่ยน้องชายคน
ที่ 3 ก็เลยหยิบเขาควายออกมาแล้วก็เป่า
ปูทำให้ใช่ทำให้บ้านแล้วก็ประสะบ้านของ
เอ่อพระราชวังนะคะบ้านของพระราชากับเจ้า
หญิงใช่มั้ยบ้านจะมากพใช่บ้านใหญ่มาพัง
พังลงมาเลยค่ะเจ้าหญิงกับพระราชาก็เลยตาย
อยู่ในนั้นน้องชายคนที่ 3 ก็
เลย
รอดแล้วก็มีหมวกกระเป๋าแล้วก็เขาควาย
เหมือนเดิม
อ้าวจบเค้าเป็นคนดีมั้ยน้องชายคนที่ 3
เนี่ยนั่นสิเค้าเป็นคนดีใช่มั้ยคะหรือคน
ไม่ดีคะเค้าเป็นคนดีหรือคนไม่ดีคะทำไม
เค้าถึงไม่ตายเไม่ตายค่ะสอจบแต่คนดีๆตาย
เอ้อแล้วก็จบใช่เนี่ยนิทาครู
ฟ้าทำให้ทุกคนแบบ
ะ
อะไรงงมั้ยคะนักเรียนจบแล้วใช่มั้ยจบแล้ว
ค่ะออนักเรียนคิดว่ายังไงนจบนิทานเรื่อง
นี้ของครู
ฟ้าสอนว่าอะไรไม่รู้ค่ะครูฟ้าก็ไม่รู้
เหมือน
กันไม่รู้นะคะสอนว่าต้องเดินไปค้นหา
เรื่อยๆหรอเรื่อยๆหรือเปล่าไม่รู้เหมือน
กันไม่ทราบเหมือนกันนะคะแต่ตอนนี้เนี่ย
มันหมดเวลาแล้วใช่มคะูเรรียนอใช่ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวไว้เจอกันในครั้งถัดไปเนาะครูฟ้า
ได้ค่ะโอเคค่ะถ้าอย่างั้นวนี้ต้องลาไป
ก่อนบายบสวัสดีค่ะบ๊าย
บาย